I remember the first time I met you I
was so nervous really why I didn't have
a mustache or anything tell the audience
like explain we work together in a far
away Place yeah we go is that good yeah
it's good and I was because I um had
auditioned and I never met
you what do you mean cuz it was Co
that's right it was a it was Co I never
met you but can I tell you about what
happened at the table read okay
something happened sure and it could
have been listen it could have been a
[__] disaster for me your diarrhea or
something in m so this this is what can
I you're not aware of this you're not
aware of this but it would have been a
[__] I would have been thrown out
Hollywood I think okay this sounds great
how did I miss this I never told you why
not I'm telling you now
okay right so a week before we did the
table read right because everyone you
know there there's all these stars on
everyone's around the world cuz we did
it through Zoom that's right we did we
did right wow so one of your guys calls
me and goes yo the whole movie is not
casted so you're going to have to read
these parts mhm yes other parts than the
parts I'm doing right so he gave me 20
names yeah 20 right that was my decision
but some so I was like well have Bobby D
it he's great he can do anything his
character I know love it so all week
long I memorized every line oh
no you know it's a table read not a
table recycle I know but I was so
nervous I didn't want to [__] up so I
hired a guy came over all day long I did
other people's right and it was a lot of
parts so I was the hired guy I didn't
that's that's right you was you I had no
idea you that it gets worse now I feel
so one minute before we start I text a
guy and I go are you sure I'm doing all
these parts and he goes oh no no no no
you only think doing these two but if I
hadn't asked Eli you would have been I
would have been reading somebody else's
same and talking for the jumping in same
time yeah yeah and it would have been so
[__] embarrassing that would have
been
great I'm so sad it so embarrassing I'm
so sad that that didn't
happen because everyone would have been
like is there an issue with Bobby like
he know is he like he was cast as this
part but now he's reading everyone
else's L why is he doing that and
they're like is he going to be like this
on set like I know he wants extra parts
but you can't like you can't really like
play two people in the same movie that
easily seems weird I know it would have
been a disaster imagine so great I would
have been dude and then so when I you
know I was a fan of your acting I know
and I when I met you you were dude I
remember them yeah I went to set and I
and and went to meet you and you pulled
me aside and we had like a 10-minute
talk and as soon as you opened your
mouth I was like okay I'm good you so
like you know you just took all the
fears away from me oh that's great well
look everyone always has that little bit
of nervousness but you cast people for a
reason because you trust them and you
sort of trust your instinct and you're
like you don't know nobody knows it's
all just like it's this kind of like I
said a faith-based system you just think
yeah this will probably work but you
just have a sense I was like and I'd
seen you in love and I'd seen obviously
Mad TV there's so many things I'd seen
you in and I was like I [__] love
Bobby Lee and weirdly I wasn't watching
or like listening to the podcast I only
like knew you from acting wow from
acting stuff wow so I was just like
Bobby Le you were just one of my
favorites and I was like we need to
write a role for Bobby Lee I actually
wrote it I was like and they were like
and they like what is this character WR
like I have this idea for this part and
it's really funny I was like it should
be Bobby Lee I think just putting him in
this movie in this world would be so
much fun so when the strike is resolved
and things are done we can talk about it
more open it but it was a pleasurable
experience but you were great to work
with Bobby really thank you and it it
was a dreamy experience and I want to
just I just want to say that out loud
you know like that I'm not nervous
anymore I'm not nervous anymore I look
at you I'm like uh you're
like you're like now when you open your
mouth I think I could even [__] in that
mouth
not
intimidated not nervous at all no stage
fright I want where Rob what happened